37 years since the first Evil Dead ya
film you having met some adjustments
yeah your character now wears check it
out
a man girdle yeah now we're a man girl
tell us tell us what's going on there
these are the little things that help
the middle-aged man get his swagger back
uh-huh that was a very early Spanx model
yeah yeah it looks like it um pan made
handmade very nice and very useful and
as you can see you can't even tell can't
even tell you can't hey yeah you haven't
breathed since you've been out you know
the character also has dentures yeah
yeah that's just [ __ ] right sure of
quarter that'll happen but I can take
those out if I need to now well I mean
that's yeah yeah right the crowds
decision not ours uh now is it true a
lot of speculation about the first Evil
Dead movie because it is gone down in
folklore is this amazing achievement
there's talk and there's rumors I don't
know what's true and what's not true
some people say that you guys got
incredibly high for some of the scenes
in the first Evil Dead true or false
uh high you're talking about marijuana
yes is that it yeah you're accusing me
of smoking marijuana on national
television and you want me to actually
smell that I did wear it we're in
California man yeah I went here as a
doctor's card you know we did we did in
fact smoke marijuana because we had
heard in the famous Jack Nicholson five
you know five Easy Pieces no a Easy
Rider Easy Rider that he spoke like 47
joints before he shot that scene and we
thought well if he can go on to become a
very famous notable actor we could do
the same thing right and I had never
smoked before right I was 21 and you
went from zero to 47 joints yeah well we
also found out that the weed in
Tennessee was pretty good apparently
more powerful yeah yeah and so we did
not really film the scene successfully
everything kind of went into stereo but
I did discern voices of the crew going
this was a really bad idea
we felt most of it over again but we did
continue to smoke marijuana because
that's what our characters would have
done good for the crap yeah right all
right do it for the crap
you